toc toc toc spéciale aux révisions ils
sont tous je vous le dis habillé d'un
raid dans des pays différents regarder
on a même fait une porte vraiment et la
porte il ya eu un boulot sur la boulot
de fait là je suis désolé a franchement
autant d'habitude un décor on n'est pas
au top mais la tonne alors là ça vient
sceller 3e v2 cergy-pontoise conclut la
porte on dirait les 3b de serge et vient
de strasbourg tu essaies ils ont fait le
parlement européen c'est magique c'est
le pape alé lô ni bâton josé marti toc
toc
prenez le cas total qui est là c'est
l'angleterre angleterre brûlé aux ventes
elles
[Applaudissements]
et encore
mais ça me va super bien merci
ça change quoi de d'habitude jules est
en angleterre brûlé balle mais c'est bon
on avait compris bercy attention cette
attaque aveugle alors et vous avez brisé
le public
merci vous êtes et sinon vous êtes qui
il est titulaire on est alors on voulait
travailler avec moi tu combien de temps
huit ans et gbagbo merci élite
toc toc toc
on n'est pas preneurs techniquement on
est pas prêt monsieur alors on va leur
faire
toc toc toc qui portent bien c'est qui
c'est par toyota au portugal qui parlent
tous vers les plus hauts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
bah non j'ai préféré bernès pour
l'instant mais vous n'étiez pas mal non
plus et le style portugais va très bien
les portugais sont très beaux gosses ah
oui ah oui je vous le dis portugais
portugais c'est un très beau peuple non
mais c'est vrai que j'adore
ils sont très très beau gosse à chaque
fois la jouer au portugal je voyais
aussi beau gosse et de ses belles meuf
vous avez quand même très amoureux d'une
portugaise mans ah ouais bah je suis
allé un jour au portugal j'ai tourné une
pub mais pour moi oui je tourne plus
pour bouygues telecom c'est pas vrai
toujours noté que c'était très simple
c'est à l'eau ouais la boucherie vous
avez dit pieper
elle m'a dit oui et ça vous gêne pas
pour marcher c'est vrai et s'était
réalisé s'était réalisé par michel
hazanavicius et oui celui qui a fait au
ss 110r celui qui a fait dix artistes
est l'un des plus grands réalisateurs si
ce n'est le plus grand que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs michel attention toc toc toc
toc
non mais c'est pas ça jean-michel
jean-michel ti jean michel mais non mais
non mais c'est pas jean michel métais
coup été tuées en biens non tu reviens
il est pas rentré qui est déjà sorti ça
va affecter les sorties attention un
autre qui est là mais alors pas toc toc
toc avc moi mais c'est qu'ils toit basse
et la hongrie
on
refaites refaite c'est la hongrie mais
d'abord total alors oui là ça marche
c'est la hongrie la hongrie que la
hongrie hongrie qui veut qu'il habite à
pest mai mais là on lui qui à part dont
il ay pauvre elle apporte ce qu'on a
comme nadal hongrie l'an mil avoir envie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'en veux tu me dis pas où sont à
caméra je suis pro j'ai raté mon entrée
alors français sacha distel ou pas
j'ai commencé alors assez drôle et nos
longues et allez ça m'agace mais non
commencés mais chez vous de ce soir va
pas le refaire
c'est très bien pour les fans de
pression vous trouverez sur un star ça
va bien aller
on y va cayla toc toc toc bruxelles a
reconnu ses quais ligne l'actrice va
baisser darty l'autriche qui la tristana
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est à double creux grancabrio ouais
c'est triste on va bien le petit train
sans merci
ouais voilà bien sociaux prennent la
donner un petit conseil de producteurs
oui jusqu'au nous en sommes 2,6 et ne
pouvait se mettre peut-être là comme ça
à savoir les gens qui rentraient face à
la caméra au mali la raison mais oui tu
as envie de lui dire d'aller se faire
[ __ ]
qu'est ce t'en penses tu ris non c'est
une tunisie voici juste producteurs
comme sa meilleure je pas alors tu aimes
bien oui mais lui c'est un amour il a
même pas joué à sa main c'est du plaisir
avec la syrie est ce que je peux donner
un conseil de coiffeur way le dessous de
bras en toc ça ne va pas c'est vrai que
je te vois pas ça laisse à des gars
comme tes bourreaux la la coupe et
aujourd'hui cela est coupé aujourd'hui
les tout couper les cheveux allez allez
hop toc toc ac plus fort on n'entend pas
toc toc c'est l'espagne l'espagne qui
est ce pagne s'il tonne
et
[Musique]
pas mal quand même si tout ça va ouais
c'est pas la meilleure attention à les
toc toc toc tac tac tac c'est la grèce
le pays a pas là de masse corporelle à
la lourdeur en tout cas aulas est sur la
galaure l'agasc gré ce qu'on attend pour
être heureux on a pu la tenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il bouge mais on fera la fête a bien sûr
voilà venait me sauver je me rassure je
vais vite me sauver mais attention à les
prochains tomes stocks à bâcher est une
voie regarde comme ça c'est maxime
danemark kaki danemark dame marre de
cette nana là
marre de cette nana j'étais venu
et
alors
l'écart pour l'instant c'est le meilleur
donc c'est carré c'est bien c'est dans
la caméra est fort bravo jeune serveuse
c'est le meilleur ces prophéties cas et
c'est clair et c'est beau il prêt pour
le prime c'est par faire il est prêt il
est prêt attention tant qu'acteur et en
homme du nord irlande du nord du nord
qui dans le coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce qu'à chaque bon sens qu'il entame
c'est pas ça mais j'aurais bien qu'un
jour on trouve un chapeau matagne parce
que le problème si je peux pas mais les
chapeaux je les pose mais non mais vous
allez voir la différence entre vous et
moi à vérité c'est ça regarde et cyril
hanouna et jean luc lemoine voilà y'a
une différence de cuillé aussi au mois
pour sa flamme à quelque chose allait
toc toc toc qui est là c'est la suisse
la suisse qui est suisse souhaite
wissman pas biya l'eau
[Applaudissements]
à
m
c'est un label naïve banale amène à ima
les toc toc toc mais non ils ont manqué
bien jean michel maire qui avait une
surprise elle a préparé une surprise
toc toc toc chez la chatte à celle h f
[Applaudissements]
d'accord dans un vaste vous l'aurez
compris tout ça pour ça merci merci à
lui bravo à lui vous